the White House's top public health
advisor warns Georgia's governor against
reopening the economy too quickly vice
president Mike Pence says the corner
virus epidemic could be largely in the
past by early June corta virus deaths in
nursing and long-term care facilities
top ten thousands hi I'm Jason Bellini
with the latest reporting on the corona
virus crisis from The Wall Street
Journal I would advise him not to just
turn the switch on and go because there
is a danger of a rebound dr. Anthony
Fauci cautions the governor of Georgia
against rolling back restrictions too
soon Republican governor Brian Kemp
announced earlier this week that
non-essential businesses including hair
salons and gyms would be able to reopen
as early as Friday if they follow state
social distancing and sanitation
guidelines president Trump also
criticized the governor for moving too
soon but said that Kemp quote must do
what he thinks is right Georgia is one
of several states that are starting to
loosen restrictions as jobless claims
have hit record numbers in recent weeks
the House is expected to vote on a
nearly five hundred billion dollar aid
package today in an interview with The
Journal Vice President Mike Pence voiced
optimism about the country's progress in
tackling the corona virus and said the
nation is past the peak by early June we
could be at a place where this
coronavirus epidemic is largely in the
past though concerned about the
lethality of the virus pence said the US
will be prepared if there is a second
wave of infections pointing to new
medicines a Wall Street Journal survey
found at least 10 thousand seven hundred
fatalities in nursing homes and
long-term care facilities though some
states haven't reported data on deaths
and long-term care facilities the survey
looked at more than 35 states
Massachusetts West Virginia and others
have been trying to increase testing for
older residents and staffers meanwhile
two newly reported deaths in California
including a woman who died in early
February suggest the first coronavirus
fatalities took place earlier than
health authorities believed
raising two big questions about the
timeline of the pandemic in the US